hey everyone and welcome back to the
channel sorry about my brief Hiatus to
make a toolish video about school versus
software but at the end of the day I had
a collaboration opportunity and I had to
take it because no one wants to
subscribe to my channel even still no
one wants to subscribe to my channel
because I'm too ugly so that means I'm
going to revert to the basics and make
some more systems design videos let's go
ahead and get into it alrighty so today
we'll be talking about Hadoop which is a
distributed computing framework so if
you're anything like me two years ago
you've probably seen this term many many
places and uh well you know maybe you're
smarter than me but at least I had no
clue what it was and I thought it was
just some made up word so let's talk
about what it actually is Hadoop is
really useful for a couple of things and
in this video I'm going to be talking
about one of two of them the first is
data storage which it does through the
Hadoop distributed file system hdfs and
the second is Big computations which it
does via things like mapreduce or spark
both of which deserve their own video
but for this one I'm going to be
sticking to hdfs the Hadoop distributed
file system because it kind of builds up
the foundation of Hadoop and why it's so
useful so let's go ahead and talk about
it hdfs like I mentioned is a
distributed file store and the thing
that's so good about it is opposed to
just having a bunch of different
computers in a cluster and being you
know kind of Hardware agnostic treating
every computer as if it was the same the
storage is actually rack aware and so
that means we take advantage of the
location of every single computer in
order to minimize things like Network
latency when sending and reading files
and so again the fact that it's
distributed also means that it is Fault
tolerant I mean not inherently but in
this case hdfs is Fault tolerant and
that's very important for why we use it
and the very basic architecture of this
thing is we have two types of
kind of elements in our system one is
that we have the name node and the
second or that we have a bunch of data
nodes so a very high level overview is
the name node is for metadata
and the data nodes are for storage
so let's go ahead and talk about that
name node a little bit more like I said
it is a metadata store so kind of a
couple of things about the name node
what does it actually tell us well first
off it tells us all the replicas
that store a given file and also the
version of that file on them you can
actually overwrite a file with a newer
version and as a result replicas could
technically have different versions in
theory this shouldn't be happening very
often because hdfs claims strong
consistency but we'll see in a little
bit that it's possible for things to get
a little bit out of whack and so the
name node which stores all of this file
metadata and it keeps all of this data
in memory which is just a slight
optimization to make sure that when a
client goes ahead and reads from the
name node or writes to the name node
that is going to be a little bit quicker
well what if the name node were to go
down another nice thing that we have is
a right ahead log on disk saying all the
operations that we have this is a good
middle ground between basically you know
having to put every single thing in disk
with an index or something that would
take a while to write and instead keeps
it to a nice sequential right which is
relatively quick while maintaining fault
tolerance also if we wanted to do an
optimization here which I think Hadoop
actually does you can occasionally
snapshot this guy right here and then
snapshot the location in the right ahead
log so wal index and then once you have
your snapshot and your wlal index you
can just replay all of the changes from
the red ad log from that point on but
that's kind of a small detail it's not
that important
so when the name node starts up
basically it's going to ask each of
those data nodes recall that the data
nodes are the ones actually holding the
files what files it holds and also what
versions and so in Hadoop you have this
configurable replication number right
let's imagine it's three in this case as
we can see every single file has three
replicas that hold it and what the name
node will do is say okay I just started
up I only see the two data nodes are
holding this file in particular let's go
ahead and replicate that to one more
data mode
cool so let's also talk about reading
files because this is relatively simple
and then we'll talk about writing after
that so basically in Hadoop we expect to
be reading data a lot of times and
writing it hopefully very few because
the writes are very expensive we're
talking about Big Data here and so we're
writing big files reading them on the
other hand should be relatively common
especially if we're doing a lot of data
computations with the same sets of data
or if we're building a database on top
of hdfs
so again a lot of reads not too many
writes so step one is pretty simple we
basically go to the name node and say
what's the file location now let's say
this guy says data node a
so now step two for the client is the
name node is going to respond with the
best replica so keep in mind here that
there are three
data nodes and the one that's actually
closest to the client is data node a so
the name node is actually smart enough
to realize hey we can actually benefit
our client a little bit by telling it a
specific replica that is going to have a
lower Network latency width for example
B is further away
and so we wouldn't want to be reading
from there that's just going to cost us
time and so as a result what the client
can do is so that when it reads this
file in the future as opposed to having
to do step one again every single time
we can just go ahead and cut that down
because we're going to Cache the file
location locally and then from there
every single time we want to read this
particular file we just go ahead and
read it from data node a
simple enough hopefully makes sense
let's now talk about writing files this
is a little bit more complicated but
still not too bad okay so basically when
we're writing a file at least for the
first time not when we're overriding it
as I try to get the zoom working
basically what we want to do is say when
we're picking a location of replicas the
name node is trying to do so in a rack
aware manner so step one is going to be
the client says I have a file I want to
go ahead and write it to Hadoop it's
going to ask the name node what to do
the name node is going to say okay here
are the replicas that you're going to
have to write this thing to and one of
them is going to be designated the
primary now ideally the name node is
going to try and pick a primary node to
write to that is actually close to the
user right so again the user is located
over here data node a is over here in
data center one which is the one that is
closest to the user so the name node can
actually be smart about that and then in
addition another smart thing that it can
do is actually be smart about replica
education it would be kind of useless if
we put one replica in all three of these
data centers because the truth is the
likelihood that two data centers are
going to die is pretty low so what we
can actually do is pick only just two of
the data centers right here forget about
data center three and then we can keep
two of the replicas in one data center
so that the network latency is minimized
between data node a and data node B the
reason we care about minimizing the
network latency between data node a and
data node B is that that file is
actually going to be written from data
node a to data node B so you might be
thinking huh that's weird so the client
is actually just writing to one data
node and then that right gets pipelined
all the way through the replicas as
opposed to just doing three writes and
you would be correct the client is only
going to do one right here
and we're going to be doing something
called replication pipeline
so let's go ahead and talk about that
the replication pipeline is a pretty
simple concept basically we have a
primary a secondary and a tertiary
replica at least in this case and all
the client now has to do is write once
and from there every single replica is
going to write to the other replicas in
the chain
and then they're going to receive
acknowledgments back through the
pipeline
and eventually that's going to be
getting back to the client now what if
it doesn't because things can fail so
what if we're only able to get this
thing into a so this guy works and then
right over here instead this guy fails
so neither B nor C is able to get the
right the client does not receive an
acknowledgment and now we're in trouble
because a actually has the updated
version of our file and B and C don't
what this means in this case is that our
system is not strongly consistent
because we can have replicas that have
out-of-date versions of the file now a
couple of different possibilities exist
here for one we can just have the client
give up and accept the fact that this
thing is going to be eventually
consistent you know the name node could
always pull the files on B and C at some
point see they have outdated versions
and then tell them to get updated or
Additionally the client can say
I didn't
get an ack
try again
and in theory you could try again until
you do get an act but obviously if for
some reason you know there just was no
network connection between A and B then
that's going to be a problem and you're
never going to get one and then again
it's just not strongly consistent so if
you hear that hcfs is that's a lie but
it certainly does try to be
okay the final thing we're going to talk
about is something known as high
availability hdfs so surprisingly this
took a while before it was standard in
Hadoop but uh yeah it pretty much needs
to be there because otherwise you will
have a lot of outages So speaking of our
name node if you've been thinking about
why the hell is there only one of them
you would be correct for a long time
there was only one name node and that's
a problem because if that thing goes
down
we are in trouble you know there's no
one else to orchestrate reads and writes
and be a metadata store so we need some
way of having a backup name node if this
thing is to go down and the way that uh
Hadoop has chosen to do so is we use
something like zookeeper so if we recall
zookeeper is a strongly consistent
way of achieving a distributed log via
consensus
so we've got three nodes they're running
a consensus algorithm where basically
the majority of nodes have to have a
write before it's considered committed
and this allows us to create
linearizable storage so that basically
we're taking our right ahead log
from the primary name node and putting
it into this distributed log that is
held on zookeeper that way we can just
have our secondary name node going ahead
and Performing State machine replication
can't write and what state machine
replication really is fancy lingo for is
just read everything from the write
ahead log store it in memory you're good
to go now if for some reason this thing
goes down zookeeper is going to say
Europe
and then the secondary name node can
take over and everyone else in the
cluster who can be connected to
zookeeper because it's a service
Discovery mechanism can basically just
say all right I'm going to be listening
to the secondary name node from now on
and then we're good to go
okay so quick conclusion here because I
have to get to the gym Hadoop is
basically a huge building block in
distributed computing it not only allows
us to work with big data in a rack aware
way which is very important but it is
also something that a lot of other
systems build upon we're going to be
talking about a database hbase soon that
builds on top of Hadoop and uses it in
order to make fast and scalable storage
and then of course also if we want to
make massive computations over just
unstructured data in general things like
log files or metrics or sensors or any
of that we're probably going to be
dumping it into Hadoop first and then
running a batch job like a mapreduce or
a spark job and we'll talk about the
differences between those so guys hope
you enjoyed this video it should serve
as hopefully a decent introduction to
hdfs and I will see you in the next one
where we talk about applications